agace tâche maëlys livèche à rallye
chasse pareil des plantes sauvages qui
ne demande qu'à finir dans nos assiettes
ou housewives préférées août et à ça ça
fait passer à la robe baie et si ces
plantes n'avaient qu'un porte parole ici
au québec ce serait peut-être lui je
suis yvan perroud je suis un formateur
comme estime sauvage dans une classe
intéressant de connaître si lente risque
des bois le persil sauvage de cerfeuil
sauvage
ainsi bernard pillonel le prouvèrent
seriez étonnés de voir les faibles
quantités d'aliments nordique sauvage
que ça prend pour bien nourrir son homme
quand on dit cuisine nordique on pense
souvent la scandinavie le nomma au
danemark par exemple un restaurant qui a
été sacré plusieurs fois meilleures
cuisines du monde
moi je trouve que dalmat quand est
brillant et intelligent
damien véhiculer cette cuisine là et de
se l'approprier quelques à part normand
laprise vient d'ouvrir un nouveau
restaurant le beaumont ya plus abordable
qu'un toqués et son mantra c'est de
sublimer les produits 10 au québec la
cuisine boréale on peut l'appeler tel
quel on l'a fait depuis toujours les
amérindiens faisait mais une cuisine
ultra local sauvage ça reste une niche
pour l'instant
et dans cette niche il ya notamment 96
une tonne
c'est mon gars de mon âge et pierrine
plus frais plus goûteux sainte et la
cale caroit casseurs et son garde manger
son jardin sauvage elle préféré que ce
soit plutôt confidentielle faut que ça
arrête sa petite échelle sinon ça serait
pas dieu râ sauf qu'il y à une demande
et yvan perroud le voit très bien dans
les formations qu'ils les ateliers qu'il
anime
vous sentez un appétit pour ça il ya mon
dieu c'est épouvantable c'était à damas
face voilà alors à se presser au
portillon comme on dit est en pleine
effervescence
ce nouveau mode de vie rustique se
dessine à travers surplus l'un qui ont
besoin que l être humain au de fusionner
avec la nature les forces vives de la
nature qui vivent en adéquation avec les
saisons le cueilleur et le chef sont sur
la même longueur d'onde
il faut pour une meilleure interaction
avec les sols prenez un jardin jeu
singes ardin sur la ferme je dire qu'il
fait pousser des carottes maintenant
tourner les pouces sauvage qui pousse
qu'on appelle les mauvaises herbes
hockey qui possède entre les mauvaises
herbes sont aussi bons même mieux plus
goûteuse souvent que les herbes qu'elle
soit faire pousser
alors ça prend des déjà dit qu'ils
connaissent ou qui vont porter autant
d'attention à ce qui à côté
qu'est-ce qu'elle légumes kg comment
vous a fait ça sans jardin de bonnes
mauvaises herbes
ici j'ai la livèche dictaphone non non
c'est comme ça c'est comme un super
séries je comprends le céleri qu'un
soutien existent non c'est vrai c'est
beaucoup facile qu est ce qu elle c'est
vrai yvan perron ne se promènent pas en
forêt il récolte en forêt la partie
comestible dans l'est toujours libre de
l'accueillir ou de laisser en place pour
que bien en agriculture on plante on
doit récolter ce n'est perdu le plan
propose se reproduire d'helmand alors
quand en plus de commerces et sauvage
nordiques tout 70e se passe de nuit et
ses plans de se passerait aussi de trop
de publicité de trop de marketing
c'est comme un mot bio peter watts tout
ça naturel en direct c'est tellement
utilisé maintenant même par les grosses
compagnies que ça regarde me sauveur
choquet
alors au delà de la mode avec tout ce
qu'on a à portée de main on commence par
quoi pour donner une vraie signature
sauvage à notre cuisine et nous nous
vient de regoûter le sapin baumier
l'épinette blanche lunettes noires le
mélézin et la pruche clottu occidental
ce serait normal alors en attendant il
continue d'être ce trait d'union entre
le sous bois et l'assiette
[Musique]